الى حرائق الغابات في كندا ومن مقاطعه
البرتا متابعه لهذه الحرائق والوضع
هناك معنى من غرب كندا ينضم الينا ناصر
الحسين ناصر كيف هو الوضع الجهود المبذول
حتى الان ونرى المطر حتى على
عدسه الكاميرا حيث تقف ناصر
هذه الامطار هذه السماعه عبد القادر الان
كندا على مستوى الفيدرالي من شرقها الى
غربها بالفعل تواجه كارثه بيئيه وترصد لها
المليارات والكثير من المساعدات الدوليه
هذه من السماء هذا اليوم هذه الامطار
ستطفئ بعض الحرائق اعطيك عبد القادر
نموذجا مما يحدث الان في الاحراج ترى هذه
الاحراج ببلده ايفلز على بعد ساعتين من
ادمنتن اكبر المدن ما تبقى من الدخان لمده
يومين كانت هناك حرائق وعمل رجال الاطفاء
بقوه دون انقطاع ليلى نهار في محاوله
لاطفائها الان يسيطرون عليها بسبب هذه
الامطار التي نزلت لكن يجب ان لا ننخدع
بهذا المشهد حقيقه لانه لاحظ معي كميه
الخسائر الان التي تواجهها كندا هناك
ملايين واقول ملايين الهكتارات التي ضاعت
بهذا الشكل بسبب هذه الحرائق وتحولت هذه
الغابات الى حطام خساره
يا هائله في البرتا حيث اوجد الان هناك
على الاقل
270 حريقا في هذه اللحظه ونحن نتحدث لم
نتمكن للوصول اليها بسبب السلطات التي
تقطع الطرق 275 حريقا مشتعلا في هذه
اللحظه نشط لم يتمكنوا من السيطره الا على
حوالي 50 او 60 منها وبالتالي
التحدي كبير جدا وهائل هناك فرق دوليه تصل
الان من مختلف الدول كثير من المساعدات
لكن هذا المشهد يتكرر لم ما زال مستمرا في
الاحراش البرتا لوحدها خسرت حتى اللحظه ما
يقرب من مليار
وخمسمائه مليون 500 الف هكتار حجم
الخسارات بالغ وهذا سيستمر على مدى الصيف
لعده اشهر هذا المشهد ورائي هو الذي
سيكون في كندا ويبدو ان الكنديين بداوا
الان يتعايشون مع هذا الواقع الجديد
ناصر الحسيني بالمقاطعه البرتا في غربي
كندا شكرا جزيلا لك